and we are joined now by Senator Tim
Scott of South Carolina he is the only
black Republican in the Senate good
morning senator Scott I wanted to start
beneath all the smoke over the weekend
our calls for systemic change but the
White House National Security Advisor
Robert O'Brien over the weekend said I
don't think there's systemic racism
99.9% of our law enforcement officials
are great Americans he said you yourself
have described being stopped seven times
in a year do you think there's systemic
racism and how should we address it
well there's no doubt that our nation
the original sin was that of racism this
is a reason why in the Constitution I
was 3/5 of a man the question is what's
changed since then we've made a lot of
progress but let's just be clear there's
a lot of progress still to be made one
of the reasons why I've encouraged the
White House to take a look at having the
Department of Justice focus on race and
justice it's because it's one of the
areas where Americans want fairness if
there's a place in this nation that we
need to have leaps in the right
direction it's in our justice system and
fairness one of the things we all
celebrated Republicans and Democrats
blacks and whites was the criminal
justice reform package that was passed a
couple of years ago because there was an
unfair application of the law in
sentencing and we wanted to see that
corrected uhaah you saw people coming
together Cory Booker myself the
president Van Jones all working towards
the same outcome if we took that same
energy and focus first on mr. Floyd is
dead because the officer murdered him
mr. Oberoi is dead because two guys in a
pickup truck shot him in the middle of
the street at 1:00 p.m. for someone to
suggest that aren't racial challenges
and patterns is for someone to be blind
and so we cannot deny the truth but we
at the same time I just said this
recently we need to address this issue
this very difficult issue by recognizing
that you can both make progress and have
parts of it look like regression we have
to see both sides of the picture it's
not a a binary choice is the choice of
frog
and sometimes there's a regressive state
we can make them both work better better
if we're focused but senator if if
you're not acknowledging the problem as
the National Security Advisor does not
seem to be how do you change something
you're not even acknowledging well
there's about 340 million nine hundred
ninety nine thousand other Americans
that we can all work together to do so
the fact that one person doesn't see it
the way that it should be seen that it's
clear and evident for me when I walk
into the Capitol I'm stopped
even with my Senate pin on because I'm
an African American they didn't believe
my pin was mine I I get it but I'm not
going to focus my attention in the midst
of this challenge on one individual who
got it wrong I want to focus my
attention on folks like John Lewis that
peaceful protesting led to systemic
change in our nation if all we do is
celebrate the negative and frankly I
know it sells better we'll miss the very
important point the essence of the point
is every single American wants to
understand their own intrinsic value and
want to allow that to be expressed
publicly when you can't go for a jog as
an african-american man that that
questions whether or not your intrinsic
value is on par with every other
American so we need to wrestle with
these very significant issues for those
who believe that racism is dead and gone
and that 99.9% of any group as fewer
they're just living in a different
universe I will say that the vast
majority of law enforcement officers are
good but we need to deal with the ones
that are not as well senator you've
spoken with the president you told him
that you were reportedly that you
thought his first tweets calling some of
the protesters thugs and that the
looting when the looting starts the
shooting starts was not constructive he
has since offered condolences to the
family but he has not discussed solving
a systemic problem do you want him to
address that has he indicated to you he
will well the president I didn't have a
constructive conversation on Saturday I
thought he was very much in a listening
mode and I thank him for that we did
talk about next steps going forward
certainly I suggested that it would be
good for us
to have a conversation with some of the
leading voices in the african-american
community and some of the leading voices
in the law-enforcement community without
a bunch of cameras though I want a real
raw conversation where people get to
understand and appreciate the other's
perspective I did that with congressman
trey Gowdy in South Carolina after the
Walter Scott shooting after the church
shooting I wanted to bring communities
of color together with law enforcement
so that we could actually have a
conversation without cameras it
literally led to law enforcement
officers and pastors doing ride-alongs
and having a raw conversation I never
forget a black pastor who said I'm
afraid for my life but I'm more afraid
for the life of my child when he's
driving down the road that's a serious
challenge do you think very quickly
senator do you think the president sees
that there's a systemic problem as you
do I do think he does I talking to the
president he said very clearly with the
actions in Minnesota was terrible and he
even questioned of what is going on with
the other three officers so when we have
a president who's willing to listen
we're in a better position I hope that
over the next seven days you'll see some
skin on the bones of some of the
recommendations I have a piece of
legislation called the Walter Scott
notification act that would help us
understand the police shootings around
the country there's no one place you can
go to get the information today so I'm
hoping that we'll see that and other
pieces of legislation going forward all
right senator Scott thank you so much
for being with us this morning